people who are not in stem and kind of
have an outside look
at software development sometimes don't
understand how truly creative it is
reading lines of code is like reading
poetry it's an art form in itself and
it's a culture of really bringing ideas
to light
[Music]
i started coding when i was nine years
old and i've been dancing since i think
i was able to walk
my father is a dancer so it was in my
blood so there's one a where mateo is on
his own
so i had a plan in life
i had a direction i was going to be a
professional dancer
everything was lined up
and then i got cancer
it changed the whole path of my life
while i was in recovery i'm not really
good at sitting still so i was writing
software from the hospital bed i've
gotten almost obsessed like it was
something that just kept me going and
when i came back home
i wanted to dance again
i was in the midst of trying to find
ways to mix dance and technology and
that's when i came up with the idea of
the light suits and wirelessly
programming them to make really amazing
visual art
all right i'm gonna stop at this queue
when it starts
let's just see if this is right before
it even starts
we were
up hours and hours and hours writing the
software and
trying different things and it was it
was a lot of fun the end product is as
simple as me pressing one button and the
lights turn on and another button and
they change color and a few buttons and
a sequence happens
we were performing in public spaces and
the more positive reactions we got the
more confident i was to just go for it
and just a few months after that we were
on america's got talent and
the rest is kind of history it's
groundbreaking what you do it's
incredible you create everything from
zero
and it's just brilliant
we work with chris brown
deathcap for cutie
christine aguilera black eyed peas
then we also had our own show that has
been on in the heart of broadway for
several years and is touring both
nationally and internationally
it can go on and on
the future for illuminae is definitely
education
i want to be able to have
students from different backgrounds work
and collaborate together because
if you learn how to respect people who
do something different than you and have
them respect you back that kind of skill
set will really take you farther in life
[Music]
you